michael fulmer's
first pitch on a major league mound in a
major league baseball game since
september 15th of 2018. so here's jorge
chaler here's the pitch slider swung and
miss struck him out that had to feel
good for michael former didn't it yeah
his first strikeout in quite some time
it ends up on a slider here you can see
the good break he gets
solar to chase
here's the 1-1
this one lifted to right for cameron
maven hey a nice start for michael
former michael franco at the plate two
for 11 over the weekend
in cleveland
michael franco
deep into left field and that is his
first home run as a royal
he almost cleared both of detroit's
bullpens out there and the royals lead
one nothing in the second inning so
second and third and here's victor reyes
reyes on the ground in the hole modest
he models it everybody's safe and we're
tied
all right here's jacoby jones rutter's
at second and third only one away
here's the 3-1
swung on and pounded to left that ball
is gone
a three-run jack
for jacoby jones and the tigers climb on
top
slider just a great swing right there
and that's three more runs for tiger
whitneyfield singled his first time up
and whit
drills one into deep left field reyes is
back
and whitmerfield goes just inside the
left field foul pole
and the royals come right back after the
five run bottom of the second inning
it is 5-3
and now salvador perez stands in against
michael former
center field deep jones is back he's all
the way back and salvador perez hits
number two on the year and the royals
are down by one
already protecting them here well it
didn't end quite as the way michael
probably wanted it to almost three
innings of working now let's see what
whit decides to do here nobody out he
can do all of it
and that's lined up the left field line
and that is up against the wall on a
bounce
cordero scores
phillips will stop at third base and
whit merrifield is a triple shy of the
cycle and we're only in the fourth
inning and they're loaded up for ryan
o'hearn
and o'hearn hits it hard and through the
right side
phillips scores
merrifield scores and ryan o'hearn
in his first game back has driven in two
and the royals lead 7-5 after being down
5-1 salvia third ryan o'hearn at first
michael franco hit his first home run as
a royal
oh franco to left field that's deep
reyes is at defense and reyes
runs into the fence
and michael franco runs into another
home run his second of the game
this one is worth three
and suddenly the royals have a five run
lead in the fourth inning wow
what an outburst now the batter is
whitmerfield he is a triple shy of the
cycle
well he'll have to wait for another
plate appearance but he is on for the
fourth time jorge solaire he is oh for
three
and solaire drives it into deep right
field mabin is back and jorge solaire
blasts his second home run of the season
and the royals have hit five home runs
in the first five innings this is reyes
switch hitter batting left-handed
this one lifted to deep right
way back and it's gone he found the
first row
and victor reyes showcases a little bit
of that power that we were seeing at the
end of last year
early on this year
second homer of the night for the tigers
with phillips at the plate
and phillips
cranks it to deep right field and whit
will come up because that's a two run
home run
and the royals have tied a team record
tonight
with six home runs in a game so it's
14-6
and witt
is going to try and get a triple against
a pitcher he's never faced before
and he hits it in the air
somebody needs a trip and fall down or
maybe both guys need to trip and fall
down nope it didn't work
speyer's next pitch swung on hit sharply
but right at the third baseman front
though his throw is in time and the
royals do win game one of this four-game
series the final score is 14-6 as the
royals tie a franchise record with
six home runs in the ball game